il a une famille au propose en compagnie
de pierre bruneau voyage sans passeport
pierre bonneau la semaine passée nous
nous sommes quittés aussi mail nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui à port soudan
oui en effet un port soudan qui a été
fondé en 1905
lorsque la marine lorsque les bateaux à
vapeur ont remplacé l'ancien marine à
voile c'est très important comme quand
je vois beaucoup c'est très important
c'est le port le plus important de mer
rouge
mais c'est aussi un lieu de pêche
sportive
on pêche dans la mer rouge
c'est un ces régions des batailles les
requins qui donne forte à faire ou à
l'amateur ils sont partis en mer par
l'espoir de trouver un requin et vous
avez trop mais malheureusement non aux
yeux sur lui au fond là où ils se
tiennent par ce qui nous fait meilleur
nous avons tout de même pris de très
jolis poissons multicolores légende et
non pas de noms mais je les ignore mais
c'est joli
malheureusement leur couleur s'atténue
très vip ans au soleil est importante
tout meilleurs efforts ils servent de
nourriture ou ivo le confort saïd
certains de ces repentis cauvery tout à
l'heure une histoire terrible courageuse
par une terrible histoire oui voici un
peu dans son procès n'est dans son
repaire serre nous sommes ici dans un
port d'anciens pirates s'émerveiller une
gomme est un pas bien joli mais un port
d'anciens pirates pas exceptionnel mais
ces gens ignorent incident torpeur et q
mais jouer q mais avait pour principale
activité d'écumé d'exploiter les
pèlerins qui voulaient se rendre en face
à jeddah a pour le pèlerinage de la
mecque et ils sont maintenant pêcheurs
de coquilles trois cas quand on tire la
nacre au fonds sociaux suscite une
situation très noble moi je trouve
d'être piraté un bouquet oui c'est
plutôt sa vie ils sont mûrs pour les
allocations familiales
oui
il s'entraîne burqa
une très bien reçus voyez dans quelques
cigarettes pendant inspiration forte
tableau
mais cette triste pour ne plus pouvoir
ma vie dure qui fait référence
ils sont patentes et quelques fois où
ils peuvent avoir encore de bonnes
histoires à se raconter sur mon détient
que 50 ans après midi pour l'instant
mais ils ont fondé une colonie sinon ils
sont parqués les swings lagarde a
oscillé que kid rock a quitté c'est
chaud soleil avant d'être en sachet
c'est un expédient rendre vers la france
je m'excuse mais ce ne sont pas tout à
fait tout à fait des pirates repenti
alors ce sont des pirates non ils
attendent leur heure c'est ça aussi la
masse avoir en élytre et
le port qui dessert l'ancienne colonie à
smara
massa loi est une ville très soul très
humide
c'est ben oui oui oui très bon ce sont
des épices non ce sont des épices
exactement wii dont on se sert pour
faire le plat national de zig ning qui
est composée puissamment relevé qui
composait de quoi composer d'un aggoun
moutons avec une sorte de pas acide
auquel on ajoute beaucoup de ceux poivre
mélangez à votre gré bien qu'on appelle
le berbère à 6 un souk
c'est une rue ouverte
ici sans doute la tonne 1,5 m on éprouve
une meurtrière
et ici la cathédrale copte c'est un bon
départ très bon départ c'est une église
la cus toi nelly scott
pourquoi lacustre il ya une raison non
non mais parfois deux iphone protégé du
test et la russie à asmara st cyp un
prêtre copte
l'éthiopien fond de religion catholique
chrétienne juive et les visages
extrêmement j'étais un jour de la fête
du thème kate c'est la célébration du
baptême de saint jean baptiste
voici le clergé qui sort de la
cathédrale une salle il était demi
d'ailleurs car les fidèles au pacs ils
restent sur le tard grâce à l'extérieur
je n'aime pas de l'appareil et comment
vous aviez participé le fussent bien
après le fils le clergé va se rendre
auprès d'un petit étang dans la région
où il s'installera offriez toute la nuit
et le lendemain matin a lieu en fait le
véritable cérémonie oui le défilé des
évangiles les formes carrées les
parapluies sont des objets du cul
femmes
mais l'armée participe aussi à un moine
c'est un symbole c'est suffisant vous
coûteront volume en débattons de prière
il vint des instruments de musique
voyez la prière qu'ils aient agi comme
ça me garde est gratuite mais pas
rappeler que peut-être deux couleurs
chatoyantes ma supposée sophie 6 2 6 3
si si leur servent à la mesure aussi où
mme lévesque qui lie les évangiles et
tout à l'heure un officiant d'allumer
une petite bougie
et quel monde se précipitera pour
prendre de l'eau s'en asperger et on
emporter chez soi dans le petit
récipient
enfin à djibouti
e
ici le marché au bois que l'on va
chercher de l'autre côté de la baie dans
la forêt du die le marché à djibouti et
très vite presque comme tous les marchés
une permet de voir beaucoup de types 1
dizaine de couleurs
un sérieusement draper très belle cette
fois il bouge
wendy good by à gosselies en quelques
heures mais fait à celle qui a suivi
puis ces fréquences grossissement rapine
long c'est assez rare et vous voyez la
campagne se mêlent karibe la semaine il
est à peu près 23 mille kilomètres
carrés et on peut dire que dans un
presque totalité aimé qu'un champ de
pierres n'y a rien à faire pour
l'arranger lorient 9 heures
une construisent pas la pyramide non
renseigné du pays mais le procédé simple
à peu près le semblable
la matière première est à portée de la
main 2 un travail épuisant actionnaires
non on travaille uniquement une nouvelle
ère de méchants dépêcher parce que les
films y ait un an aussi souvent toute
façon c'est nous
la sagesse
par cette piste nous allons rejoindre le
lac assal tout senti combien il se
distraire à la fin du après le travail
ils sont moitié pape
bergé est aussi campagne et il reste
toujours armé car ils font souvent des
rencontres disons assez sanglante pour
ce type clé un point d'eau c'est
évidemment quelques précieux c'est une
blanche
c'est le lac assal 150 mètres en dessous
du niveau de la mer mais il faudra
creuser manchots assez chaud et en
principe on n'y va jamais en été génial
et pourtant monsieur vous avez rapporté
ses vues je suis jetée en hiver
avant il faisait d'ailleurs assez chaud
épicé masse blanche c'est petit c'est
petit ben 10
ces deux icebergs sont de celles on ne
peut pas se baigner c'est pas possible
étant poursuivi
en tout cas on est sûr de ne pas manquer
de sel la main il est exploité
d'ailleurs dû d'avant le voir à l'heure
le lac a à peu près une vingtaine de
kilomètres dans sa plus grande longueur
et de l'autre côté
que nous atteignons par la jeep sur une
piste magnifique
fêtes de cosne et du sable de celle de
sel elle n'est pas partout ceux ci
plagne c'était terriblement éblouissant
tout à fait soutenable
comment fait-on des lunettes spéciales
et de travail sans lunettes c'est un
bien me travaille sans lunettes
ils connaissent ni tabac ni l'argent ni
la cigarette ils sont tous des jeunes
qui ne se pose même pas la question
oui nous voulons pas digne en tout cas
ils exploitent le sel de cette manière
primitive et il le transporte en
ethiopie où il leur sert devenus des
changes
voici une piste
il était sur le paysage on est toujours
une garantie
le grand barrage c'est un autre désert
dans l'année dans le désert qu'est la
semaine
c'est un lac desséché qui aussi une
longueur d'à peu près de 18 kilomètres
d'un groupe des bergères semaine autour
d'un ancien puits de l'eau de houle
cette eau qui fait l'ange de bataille
aux effets pour la la région les
travertins c'est un phénomène
hydrothermales
qui se produire ou si dans certaines
régions de france j'entretiens le
travertin et cette masse de calcaire
surgit du sol révélateur d'eau
cette pétrifie en fait ils or l'eau en
jaillissant du seul une forme on
tournait l'acte i phone
le calcaire qui s'agrandit répu avec le
siècle où les milliers d'années donne
des montagnes semble à bout des rebelles
qui mineurs vous voyez là au pied de ses
passifs l'on est en ébullition et
sulfureuse
assez chaude pour qu'elle hébergeait
roumanie ils fassent fuir leurs chevaux
non conforme aux rites eurent jugé très
pratique
vous pouvez toujours leur enfance à
l'andouille of the band pouvoir
supporter précédé cette vision se trouve
vous apercevez juste avoir un chat jaune
à point puisque vous allez manger
s'appuie dans nos rangs et nous nous
réfère d'ailleurs gentiment c'est
peut-être très bon fond non sauriez vous
aviez que j'étais vous ne regrettez pas
travailler vous le système fonctionne
sur ses prix la fumée on voit la vapeur
d'eau qui sort par le sommet merci
pierre boulot et à dans quinze jours
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de pierre bruneau de
solange péters montage pierre michel rey
son pôle bonne illustration sonore
d'aunis blazer
abobo